no si è caduto sopralluogo lo avrei
messo in atto oggi in un episodio di
amon gas nella vita reale questa volta
avremo tre turni e dovremo trovare le
uova di pasqua tema caccia al tesoro di
among us nella vita reale vince chi
trova più uova di pasqua e andiamo ad
aprirle voi potete scegliere ma le
sorprese
[Musica]
questa volta le regole sono un po
diverse sono più difficili perché noi
perdiamo il nostro ruolo o crew mail o
impostori però tu non saprei se io sono
imposto recruitment e io lo saprò se tu
sei impostore più mese potremmo capitare
o entrambi impostori o entrambi crew
mail o una in coppa è uno che mai di chi
è in portoro eliminare l'altra persone
rubargli la nuova
invece i fiumi devono collaborare scrive
trovare le uova assieme unire le forze e
più uova trovano più che fa la
probabilità che vinceranno mangi
impostori vogliono solamente eliminare
gli altri rubare le uova
vi sarà super divertente questo episodio
mi raccomando mettete il tutto ciò che
un mi piace questo tenite a motori il
primo round
vai festa in un guardo ok rimetti a
posto
contiamo fino a 5 e iniziamo
l'esplorazione e la ricerca delle uova
zebre 43 domenica arancione si è
allontanato quindi io posso cercare
indisturbata qua in questa stanza di
temi anche voi se vedete qualche uovo e
prima tag per voi lasciare un mi piace
qua sotto
entro quattro secondi 4 3 2 1 o tempo
scaduto se qualcosa questo brudaglio c'è
qualcosa là sopra vedete saliamo pd
sì va bene siamo 1 a 0 che una canzone
senza al piano di sotto e vediamo cosa
sta facendo
prendiamo questo perché potrebbe
servirmi sopra
ma che sta facendo
andiamo a rubare
sta cercando di mangiarlo già è
arancione
mi dispiace per te ho vinto io basta
turno perché ho preso due uova o non
giusto notizia attento perché in realtà
era preso rapporto quando vieni
eliminato solo per me ho vinto il primo
turno male apriremo alla fine passiamo
ora al secondo marco ok ho visto che
cos'è bacchette pescara da 60 guarda ho
visto anzi così io esco a cercare
qualche uomo fuori in giardino vediamo
se trovo qualcosa
indovinate un po che cosa sono i post
ora finalmente potrò infatti del nuovo
che mi ha rubato aida per prima cosa
scegliamo l'arma questa presa ho deciso
che nasconderò l'arma in modo che lei
non lo possa vederlo sarà vanità dignità
e facendo
hai trovato qualcosa ma anche se
l'avessi trovate non te lo direi perché
no perché non mi fido di te quelli sono
un fiume hit come terna assise i crew me
si giura che sei crew meité 6 luciano
sono più merito però come allora
possiamo cercare le uova assieme un
mirino delle nostre forze giusto
bell'idea guarda ho visto qualcosa la
stop roma non ci arrivo quale di sembra
che ci sia un nuovo nascosto di 0
pensavo che merlino avesse trovato un
nuovo invece stava solo abbaiando agli
uccellini e cioè sta prendendo l'uovo da
lassù è viva è riuscito a prenderlo
continuiamo a cercare dividiamoci così
riusciamo a cercare meglio si è
esercitato rimane il giardino e io
controllo dentro casa e chiama se c'è
qualcosa qua in camera c'è qualcosa lì
in mezzo alle piante guardate era
nascosto bene questo uomo verde perché
mezzo alle piante ma lo trova
bene allora abbiamo due uova
andiamo a metterlo in cameretta
ehi che ci fai qua non ci credo e uova
oggi ho fregato ayew preso le due uova
grazie per avermi aiutato a prendere
soprattutto il primo silvio fregata ma
ecco perche ho fatto prendete lui essere
un fiume it
invece no sono l'impostore me l'ha
pagata adesso passiamo al terzo round
radio picche per l'ultimo tour l'auto
che adesso io la guardo
[Musica]
ok perché le terme non guardo affrontare
fatto sì fatto 13 32 e non vai no tu non
vai
no perché non voglio perché devo
controllare quale incamera così qualche
nuovo ok va bene allora io vado
lo sterzo età l'impostore ciao ciao si
nasconderanno berlino secondo te dove
sono le ultime tu mi aiuti a trovarle
controlliamo se c'è qualcos'altro fuori
in giardino and yahoo
e appena uscita voleva proprio lasciare
questa stanza dove potevo fare scegliere
l'arma se l'era fa dentro se ne sarebbe
subito accorta penso di scegliere un
qualcosa che si possa nascondere meglio
prendo la mia arma preferita dove si
sarà nascosta guardate ora vi sta
cercando le uova là dietro
non vedo l'ora di beccarlo parla nelle
altre uova come prima dobbiamo essere
molto discreti questa volta perché lei
ce l'ha vorrà far pagare per lo
scherzetto di prima quindi stiamo molto
attenti e discreti devo nascondere
l'arma altrimenti se ne accorgerà subito
ragazzi curati dove sono sempre a un
albero perché ho trovato un altro uovo
perché non riesco a prenderlo perché un
po in alto per ebbe paura di perdere
l'equilibrio
eccolo arancioni sta arrivando forse può
aiutarmi lui ei che ci fai sopra
quell'albero dunque adesso è un uomo qua
doveva dire prova a prenderlo ti
preoccupare adesso provo a prenderlo io
è tutto sotto controllo fa che sono
quasi un abile scalatore
bravo o no sono incastrato
non riesco a scendere una figlia molto
bene meglio che dico vi posso provare le
altre uomo devo tornare dentro prendere
un arma e arriva il nuovo bene ora
possiamo cercare l'altro uomo
indisturbati perché arancione è
incastrato sull'albero ma è caduto si è
caduto sopralluogo lo avrei
beh
ho sentito anche l'altro
[Musica]
stefano ovvero arancione è caduto
l'ultimo uovo 1 giu
[Applauso]
fermo no però tu con un impostore
anch'io sono anche tu anche io spero di
portare e ora come facciamo un'idea io
prenderò quello lì e non ti eliminerò
che ne pensi così potrò avere 4 uomo su
due lo prenderò io non ti eliminerò
anziché limite no no a 77 aspetta
facciamo una cosa io ho tre uova nei due
possiamo fare che prendiamo quell'uomo
losi viviamo a metà
e così io verrò tre e mezzo o due e
mezzo non è male come offerta che ne
pensi
secondo me stai solo provando a fregarmi
amici pensare un momento non toccare
come l'uovo collo toccare sei già l'uomo
schiacciato con la tua pancia
io voglio voli caro anche da bere è di
tutti e due abbiamo tutti e due ci siamo
eliminati
io ho trovato due uova tu quante 46
tre e mezzo perché queste di tutti e due
siccome io ne ho uno in più di te tra il
regalo una tieni quella che avevo preso
lui sta bene e creato da 333 va bene
siamo pari fuori allora se volete la
rivincita ha lasciato un bel mi piace se
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace faremo un'altra cazzo tesoro e
delle uova amore andiamo aprirli prende
la vostra seconda tanti scegliere la
vostra sorpresa preferita iniziamo siamo
da quello strascicato dalla falsa
digitale completamente distrutto
viviamo adesso il freddo la sorpresa è
un gioco di società quella mowlem veline
e questa è la mappa in cui giocare
l'uomo riferisce che io adoro crediamo
speriamo che ci sia un cane o un gatto
vediamo vediamo piedi male è sempre un
animale super carino che carina e questo
sembra un riccio secondo voi che rimane
è questo pensavo fosse un buco di 8 no
parte è vero un ripristino e cosa c'è
scritto che si sono sorprese per la
cucina vitale piedi per disperso
ridiamo
sessuale non violi marroni che cosa è
chiesto nel frattempo vitale per il
sistema sta mangiando ovviamente troppo
felice comunque la sorpresa di
quest'uomo è una capote chiusa per deco
decorare le torte e biscotti
prego di nolo dei pochi che viviamo
adesso ci ha provato una pallina
succedendo dentro la sorpresa è una
pallina con bulbo town dentro al titolo
quelli che le partite del bolzano stare
attenti però a berlino la mano di
abruzzo falsa ma non troppo si strige
rimbalza prossimo questo gigante nè per
lui nè sembra un borsello da viaggio un
portafoglio non può essere troppo grande
e forte ultimo quadri peluche che sono
le vere sorprese preferite vediamo
siamo di animale fermiamo qua e mi è
capitato il palo allora qual è stata la
nostra consapevolezza preferita per me
questa e lupin zero questa è una volta
molto bella
però la mia preferita è il riccio troppo
carino e la mostra sorpreso preferito
questo scrivete nei commenti se volete
un altro a un box di uova di pasqua
lasciate bomber mi piace ora cliccate su
una di queste 4 stelline luca su quella
che preferite
buone visioni ciao